Thomas Soul even well before Larry Elder
has been talking about this for decades
that the problem within the black
community let's say is not about race
it's not about racism against them it's
actually about fatherlessness and you'll
find it interesting when that all began
take a look uh you find that a married
couple families were much more prevalent
among blacks then than today most black
kids grew up in homes with two parents
under slavery itself and for Generations
thereafter and as late as the 1960s most
black children grew up in two parent
homes when you think about it I mean uh
centuries of slavery and generations of
Jim Crow did not destroy the black
family
but one one generation of the welfare
state ah okay so that's the part that I
want to Now link to the rest of the show
that throughout slavery throughout Jim
Crow decades Generations as he's saying
there were still more two-parent black
homes than white homes right it wasn't
until the welfare state so now we're
talking about the early 1970s when
basically the Democrats came in and they
came in with affirmative action and they
came in with all these handouts that
suddenly the black community started to
break down in the home this is just a
fact there's nothing racist about
talking uh racist by talking about that
right
[Music]
thank you